is something that i say over and over
again this is not a system belonging to
tayyip erdogan it's really never a good
sign
when a person one reversed himself in
the third person
i am a mortal being i can die
at any time and the two more importantly
has to repeatedly deny that they're
a dictator if you say ballot box
produces a dictator that will be
unfair to the ballot box process on
april 16th
turkey narrowly voted yes on a
referendum that will dramatically
reorganize the government it allows
changes that give sweeping powers to the
president
tayyip erdogan he could have complete
control of turkey's budget and military
will be able to appoint judges to the
courts without a vote can dissolve
parliament whenever he chooses and can
stay in power until 2029
this has prompted concerns that he's
becoming too authoritarian
and these concerns aren't that
outlandish mostly because turkey was
built
by an authoritarian if you look at the
arc of modern turkish history it begins
with mustafa kamal auditor
first president of the first turkish
republic mustafa kemal during the 1920s
is now granted dictatorial powers
and is himself christened ataturk
meaning father of the turks
ataturk was a military general who
created the republic of turkey out of
the collapsed ottoman empire in 1923.
during his 15 years in office he enjoyed
similar powers now held by erdogan
he used them to build turkey into a
modern and secular state turkey's new
government separates church and state
so he banned head coverings to kemal
this headgear the fez
symbolizes turkey's oriental fatalism
and ignorance
he will abolish it he put mosques under
state control
islamic traditions are shattered he made
it basically illegal to discriminate
against women
he takes pleasure in the company of
emancipated women he made women's
education
compulsory he made literacy rates rise
he made schools open to everyone to make
a modern nation
all turkey must be sent to school
ataturk also industrialized his country
under his watch the industrial sector
saw a sharp increase
and his liberal foreign policies built a
close relationship with the west
which paved the way for turkey to join
the nato alliance in 1952.
we know that ataturk succeeded because
for decades it was a modern secular
western country
like he wants it to be ataturk is
dictator so that turkey may never again
have a dictator now you have president
erdogan
president erdogan is going in literally
the opposite direction he wants to make
the country much more openly religious
he wants to get rid of a lot of what
ataturk had done but how does a
religious
conservative leader acquire so much
power in a secular country
to understand this you have to know what
happened to turkey after ataturk's death
for five decades the country was
constantly in a state of upheaval
ataturk had given the military the
responsibility of keeping turkey secular
and they did so by staging coups in 1960
71
80 and again in 1997. while the
interventions were meant to keep turkey
democratic the instability left the
country in poor shape
in the 90s and even to the early 2000s
turkey had totally
completely stale economy the gdp growth
it slowed unemployment was very high
it was seen as a very corrupt country
the government didn't function enter
recep tayyip erdogan he was the mayor of
istanbul from 1994 to 97.
two years later he was arrested for a
public reading of a politically charged
islamic poem by a turkish nationalist
turkey was still a majority muslim
country and his arrest made him popular
with many who felt oppressed by years of
the secular military rule
after a short jail sentence he formed
moderately conservative political party
the akp
which went on to win a landslide victory
in the 2002 elections
and he became prime minister of turkey
erdogan went on to pull the country out
of poverty by giving more opportunities
to turkish entrepreneurs and expanding
access to foreign markets
this led to a sharp rise in the gdp and
inflation plummeted
success even prompted efforts to join
the eu this all made erdogan wildly
popular
it was like he came onto a boat that was
listing and taking out water
and managed to get the water out of the
boat to make the boat sail straight
again
so for many years you could see why a
man like this would be as powerful as he
became
then he went too far over the next 10
years
turkey continued to grow economically
but erdogan started pushing more
islamist and authoritarian policies he
was quoted saying that he did not
believe men and women were equal
and that women were meant to be mothers
his government also began arresting
protesters
and journalists under the guise of
anti-terrorism laws
this stirred unrest in turkey's more
liberal urban areas
in 2013 there is a small peaceful
demonstration in istanbul's gezi park
to protest erdogan's plans to
reconstruct military barracks that would
include a shopping center and a mosque
seeing the demonstration as opposition
erdogan sent in riot police to remove
the protesters
which quickly attracted more protesters
it got bigger and bigger because it was
a proxy
and more from being a protest over park
to be a protest against erdogan
against how religious he was becoming
and it got violent
previously he had not been a brutal
ruler after this he became a brutal one
erdogan began removing ataturk's secular
laws more aggressively
he ended the ban on wearing headscarves
tightened restrictions on alcohol sales
and freed mosques from government
control then in 2014 erdogan was elected
president which in turkey is a
ceremonial role with little real power
but that didn't put an end to the
arrests made across the country
which indicated that erdogan was still
in charge and there were two groups of
people who were terrified by this
one they kind of secular turks who
looked back to ataturk and said
the hell's happening to our country the
other was the military
and they were the ones again who
believed that their core mission in life
was to keep turkey secular and that he
was a threat so in july 2016 they staged
a coup
and it almost worked there was just one
problem the military couldn't get the
public support this time
erdogan had found a new way to reach his
supporters
i want to encourage my people to the
streets and invite them to the airports
and together as people gather show them
by letting them come with their tanks
to see what they are going to do do it
right there to the people
erdogan had this amazing moment where he
used face time on his iphone to kind of
rally the country and say defend the
country defend us against the military
come turks come to me come help rally
around me and it worked
you had secular turks for the first time
in years defend erdogan
you had religious turks literally
streamed from mosques
into the streets to fight the military
the military overstepped
you had turkish f-16s fire rockets and
missiles at parliament
turkish tanks fire to people in the
streets that was very effective for him
erdogan emerged from the fighting more
popular than ever and ramped up his
purge of the opposition
more than a hundred thousand journalists
academics military officers and
politicians have been arrested since the
coup attempt tens of thousands remain in
detention this brings us to the recent
referendum which follows erdogan's
post-coup popularity
he set it in motion to acquire more
power and to make it permanent but the
vote was much closer than it was
anticipated
suggesting that much of the country
wants to hold on to the secular turkey
created by ataturk
and they're willing to fight for it but
i do think you're gonna have the
inevitable attention of
a president who believes he's entitled
to more power taking more and more of it
and what remains a somewhat secular
country that isn't comfortable with
giving him that power do those tensions
play out politically and in court
or do this play out in the streets if
it's actual fighting and violence
then what we know of as a democrat
turkey is over
you